[Musique]
l'électeur le 15 mai 1893
au québec une affaire de cannibalisme on
lit dans un journal un sauvage
s'accusent de cannibalisme et on raconte
qu'un autochtone dont pas ce qu'on
appelle un sauvage à l'époque était
transi par le froid
et pour passer l'hiver il ya mangé toute
sa famille
la journée suivante le 16 mai des
détails un peu plus complet on raconte
que c'est pas lui qui s'accusent de
cannibalisme
mais d'autres autochtones et qui aurait
pas manger toute sa famille
mais heureusement juste de sa fille le
lendemain 17 mai 1893 nous sommes à
montréal la patrie ou le délit witness
raconte l'histoire mais avec des détails
beaucoup plus sordides oui c'est vrai il
aurait seulement tué sa fille mais une
manière assez singulière
il lui ouvre la gorge il boit tout son
sens et tout ça devant d'autres
autochtones qui sont transis par le
froid
l'histoire fait grand bruit tout le
monde en entend parler sauf qu'un petit
problème
le lendemain le 18 mai et un journal le
journal électeurs qui seraient traquant
dans en fait c'est pour ce qui s'est
passé il faut attendre le lendemain le
19 mai pour avoir l'histoire complète
grossièrement c'est juste l'histoire
d'une famille autochtone dont quelques
membres sont tombés malades et qui ont
fui après ceux vers la côte nord où ils
ont rencontré des blancs dati c'est tout
mais l'on se dit c'est fini il y en
aurait pu d'histoire comme ça et cette
histoire là et elle est morte enterrée
mais en fait non pas vraiment le 1er
juin de la même année on retrouve cette
histoire de l'histoire de cannibalisme
en outaouais à gatineau et quatre jours
plus tard elle se retrouve de l'autre
côté de l'atlantique en france donc les
français vont associer les autochtones à
la sauvagerie au barbarisme et / ou
cannibalise
tout ça à cause d'une chose une fausseté